There is a real danger of losing
our tenure on this planet altogether.
We've got to care about
this matter of global warming
because if we don't
do anything about it
there won't be anybody here.
During my lifetime the big change
that's happened to the world
has been the development of machines
and devices and inventions.
It's about time we went back
to taking an interest
in the environment.
The Earth has an
impossible atmosphere.
For it to have happened by accident,
the odds against it run into
countless billions-to-one against.
So something's going on.
I tend to think of the Earth
as alive in a sense
like an animal or a plant
or any other living thing.
Gaia looks after us.
What happens to the planet
when more carbon dioxide
is put in the air?
The Earth will get hotter.
It will heat up to a point
where no life on it
of our kind will be possible.
Take an interest
in the natural world,
in plants and animals
and things that grow naturally.
Not worry too much
at all about schooling.
The three R's yes, they're very
important, but all the other stuff
I think could be ditched in favour
of a better understanding
of the world.
There are answers of various kinds
but I think it needs
the right sort of politics
to change people's thinking
about these things
and I'd like to see these
youngsters using their energies
and their talent in this way
rather than looking
for some techy answer
because I don't think the
answer's going to come that way.
I think we have all the things
needed to stop global warming
we're just not using them.